NARRATOR: The
following content is
provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
we should get started.
So it's good to be back.
We'll be discussing
DNA sequence motifs.
Oh yeah, we were,
if you're wondering,
yes, the instructors were
at the awards on Sunday.
It was great.
The pizza was delicious.
So today, we're going to be
talking about DNA and protein
sequence motifs, which are
essentially the building
blocks of regulatory
information, in a sense.
Before we get started,
I wanted to just see
if there are any
questions about material
that Professor Gifford covered
from the past couple days?
No guarantees I'll be
able to answer them,
but just general things related
to transcriptome analysis,
or PCA?
Anything?
Hopefully, you all got the
email that he sent out about,
basically, what you're
expected to get.
So at the level of the
document that's posted,
that's sort of what
we're expecting.
So if you haven't
had linear algebra,
that should still
be accessible--
not necessarily all
the derivations.
Any questions about that?
OK, so as a reminder,
team projects,
your aims are due soon.
We'll post a
slightly-- there's been
a request for more detailed
information on what we'd
like in the aims, so we'll
post something more detailed
on the website this
evening, and probably
extend the deadline
a day or two, just
to give you a little bit
more time on the aims.
So after you submit
your aims-- this
is students who are
taking the project
component of the
course-- then your team
will be assigned to one
of the three instructors
as a mentor/advisor, and
we will schedule a time
to meet with you in
the next week or two
to discuss your
aims, just to assess
the feasibility of the project
and so forth, before you launch
into it.
All right-- any questions
from past lectures?
All right, today
we're going to talk
about modeling and discovery
of sequence motifs.
We'll give an example of a
particular algorithm that's
used in motif finding called
the Gibbs Sampling Algorithm.
It's not the only algorithm,
it's not even necessarily
the best algorithm.
It's pretty good.
It works in many cases.
It's an early algorithm.
But it's interesting
to talk about
because it illustrates
the problem in general,
and also it's an example
of a stochastic algorithm--
an algorithm where what
it does is determined
at random, to some extent.
And yet still often converges
to a particular answer.
So it's interesting
from that point of view.
And we'll talk about
a few other types
of motif finding algorithms.
And we'll do a little bit
on statistical entropy
and information
content, which is
a handy way of
describing motifs.
And talk a little bit
about parameter estimation,
as well, which is critical
when you have a motif
and you want to
build a model of it
to then discover additional
instances of that motif.
So some reading for today--
I posted some nature
biotechnology primers on
motifs and motif discovery,
which are pretty easy reading.
The textbook, chapter 6, also
has some good information
on motifs, I encourage
you to look at that.
And I've also posted
the original paper
by Bailey and Elkin on
the MEME algorithm, which
is kind of related to the
Gibbs Sampling Algorithm,
but is used as
expectation maximization.
And so it's a really nice
paper-- take a look at that.
And I'll also post the original
Gibbs Sampler paper later
today.
And then on Tuesday,
we're going to be talking
about Markov and
hidden Markov models.
And so take a look at
the primer on HMMs,
as well as there
is some information
on HMMs in the text.
It's not really a
distinct section,
it's kind of scattered
throughout the text.
So the best approach is to
look in the index for HMMs,
and read the relevant parts
that you're interested in.
And if you really
want to understand
the mechanics of HMMs, and
how to actually implement
one in depth, then I strongly
recommend this Rabiner tutorial
on HMMs, which is posted.
So everyone please,
please read that.
I will use the same notation,
to the extent possible,
as the Rabiner paper
when talking about some
of the algorithms used
in HMMs in lecture.
So it should synergize well.
So what is a sequence motifs?
In general, it's
a pattern that's
common to a set of DNA,
RNA, or protein sequences,
that share a
biological property.
So for example, all of the
binding sites of the Myc
transcription factor--
there's probably a pattern
that they share, and you
call that the motif for Myc.
Can you give some examples of
where you might get DNA motifs?
Or protein motifs?
Anyone have another
example of a type of motif
that would be interesting?
What about one that's
defined on function?
Yeah, go ahead.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Dan. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So each kinase typically
has a certain sequence motif
that determines which
proteins it phosphorylate.
Right.
Other examples?
Yeah, so in that case, you
might determine it functionally.
You might purify that
protein, incubate it
with a pool of peptides, and
see what gets phosphorylated,
for example.
Yeah, in the back?
AUDIENCE: I'm [INAUDIBLE],
and promonocytes.
PROFESSOR: What
was the first one?
AUDIENCE: Promonocytes?
Oh, that one?
Oh, that was my name.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
And as to promoter motifs, sir?
Some examples?
AUDIENCE: Like, [INAUDIBLE]
in transcription mining site.
PROFESSOR: Ah.
Yeah.
And so you would
identify those how?
AUDIENCE: By
looking at sequences
upstream of
[INAUDIBLE], and seeing
what different sequences
have in common?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I think there's at
least three ways-- OK,
four ways I can
think of identifying
those types of motifs.
That's probably one of
the most common types
of motifs encountered
in molecular biology.
So one way, you take
a bunch of genes,
where you've identified the
transcription start site.
You just look for patterns--
short sub-sequences
that they have in common.
That might give you the
TATA box, for example.
Another way would be, what
about comparative genomics?
You take each
individual one, look
to see which parts of that
promoter are conserved.
That can also help you
refine your motifs.
Protein binding, you
could do ChIP-Seq,
that could give you motifs.
And what about a
functional readout?
You clone a bunch
of random sequences
upstream of a
luciferase reporter, see
which ones actually drive
expression, for example.
So, that would be another.
Yeah, absolutely, so there's
a bunch of different ways
to define them.
In terms of when we
talk about motifs,
there are several different
models of increasing resolution
that people use.
So people often talk about talk
about the consensus sequence
so you say the TATA
box, which, of course,
describes the actual
motif-- T-A-T-A-A-A,
something like that.
But that's really
just the consensus
of a bunch of TATA box motifs.
You rarely find the
perfect consensus
in real promoters-- the real,
naturally occurring ones
are usually one or
two mismatches away.
So that doesn't
fully captured it.
So sometimes you'll have
a regular expression.
So an example would be if
you were describing mammalian
5 prime splice sites, you might
describe the motif as GT, A
or G, AGT, or sometimes
abbreviated as GTR AGT, where
R is shorthand for either
appearing nucleotide-- either A
or G. In some motifs you could
have GT, NN, GT, or something
like that.
Those can be captured,
often, by regular expressions
in a scripting language
like Python or Perl.
Another very common
description in motifs,
there would be a weight matrix.
So you'll see a matrix where
the width of the matrix
is the number of
bases in the motif.
And then there are
four rows, which
are the four bases-- we'll
see that in a moment.
Sometimes these are described
as position-specific probability
matrices, or position-specific
score matrices.
We'll come to that in a moment.
And then there are more
complicated models.
So it's increasingly
becoming clear
that the simple weight matrix
is too limited-- it doesn't
capture all the information
that's present in motifs.
So we talked about where
do motifs come from.
These are just some examples.
I think I talked
about all of these,
except for in vitro binding.
So in addition to doing
a CLIP-seq, where you're
looking at the binding of
the endogenous protein,
you could also make recombinant
protein-- incubate that
with a random pool
of DNA molecules,
pull down, and see what
binds to it, for example.
So why are they important?
They're important
for obvious reasons--
that they can
identify proteins that
have a specific biological
property of interest.
For example, being
phosphorylated by a particular
kinase.
Or promoters that have
a particular property.
That is, that they're
likely to be regulated
by a particular transcription
factor, et cetera.
And ultimately, if
you're very interested
in the regulation of
a particular gene,
knowing what motifs are upstream
and how strong the evidence is
for each particular
transcription factor that
might or might not
bind there, can
be very useful in understanding
the regulation of that gene.
And they're also going to
be important for efforts
to model gene expression.
So, a goal of
systems biology would
be to predict, from a given
starting point, if we introduce
some perturbation-- for
example, if we knock out
or knock down a particular
transcription factor,
or over-express it, how
will the system behave?
So you'd really want
to be able to predict
how the occupancy of
that transcription factor
would change.
You'd want to know, first, where
it is at an endogenous levels,
and then how its occupancy
at every promoter
will change when you
perturb its levels.
And then, what
effects that will have
on expression of
downstream genes.
So these sorts of
models all require
really accurate
descriptions of motifs.
OK, so these are some
examples of protein motifs.
Anyone recognize this one?
What motif is that?
So it says X's.
X's would be
degenerate oppositions,
and C's would cysteines.
And H's [INAUDIBLE].
What is this?
What does this define?
What protein has this?
What can you predict
about its function?
AUDIENCE: Zinc finger.
PROFESSOR: Zinc finger, right.
So it's a motif commonly seen
in genome binding transcription
factors, and it
coordinates to zinc.
What about this one?
Any guesses on
what this motif is?
This quite a short motif.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That's
a phosphorylation.
PROFESSOR: Phosphorylation site.
Yeah.
And how do you know that?
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE] and
the [INAUDIBLE] next to it
means it's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so you even
know what kinase it is, yeah.
Exactly.
So that's sort of the view.
So, serine, threonine,
and tirocene
are the residues that
get phosphorylated.
And so if you see a motif
with a serine in the middle,
it's a good chance it's
a phosphorylation site.
Here are some-- you can think
of them as DNA sequence motifs,
because they occur in
genes, but they, of course,
function at that RNA level.
These are the motifs that
occur at the boundaries
of mammalian introns.
So this first one is the
prime splicing motif.
So these would be the bases
that occur at the last three
bases of the exon.
The first two of the intron
here, are almost always GT.
And then you have this position
that I mentioned here--
it's almost always
A or G position.
And then some positions that
are bias for A, bias for G,
and then slightly
biased for T. And that
is what you see when you
look at a whole bunch of five
prime ends of mammalian
introns-- they have this motif.
So some will have better
matches, or worse,
to this particular pattern.
And that's the average
pattern that you see.
And it turns out
that in this case,
the recognition of that site
is not by a protein, per se,
but it's by a
ribonucleoprotein complex.
So there's actually
an RNA called U1 snRNA
that base pairs with the
five prime splice site.
And its sequence, or
part of its sequence,
is perfectly complimentary to
the consensus five prime splice
site.
So we can understand why
five prime splice sites have
this motif-- they're
evolving to have
a certain degree of
complementarity to U1,
and in order to get
officially recognized
by the splicing machinery.
Then at the three
prime end of introns,
you see this motif here.
So here's the last base of
the intron, a G, and then
an A before it.
Almost all introns end with AG.
Then you have a
pyrimidine ahead of it.
Then you have basically an
irrelevant position here
at minus four, which is
not strongly conserved.
And then a stretch of
residues that are usually,
but not always, pyrimidines--
called the pyrimidine track.
And in this case,
the recognition
is actually by proteins
rather than RNA.
And there are two proteins.
One called U2AF65 that
binds the pyrimidine track,
and one, U2AF35 that
binds that last YAG motif.
And then there's
an upstream motif
here, that's just upstream
of the 3 prime splice site
that is quite degenerate
and hard to find,
called the branch point motif.
OK, so, let's take an example.
So the five prime splice site
is a nice example of a motif,
because you can uniquely
align them, right?
You can sequence DNA,
sequence genomes,
align the CDNA to the
genome, that tells you
exactly where the
splice junctions are.
And you can take the exons that
have a 5 prime splice site,
and align the sequences aligned
to the exon/intron boundary
and get a precise motif.
And then you can tally up
the frequencies of the bases,
and make a table
like this, which
we would call a
position-specific probability
matrix.
And what you could then
do to predict additional,
say, five prime splice-site
motifs in other genes--
for example, genes where
you didn't get a good CDNA
coverage, because let's
say they're not expressed
in the cells that you
analyzed-- you could then
make this odds ratio here.
So here we have a
candidate sequence.
So the motif is nine positions,
often numbered minus 3
to minus 1, would be the
exonic parts of this.
And then plus 1 to plus
6 would be the first six
bases of the intron.
That's just the
convention that's used.
I'm sure it's going to drive
the computer scientists crazy
because we're not
starting at 0, but that's
usually what's used
in the literature.
And so we have a
nine-based motif.
And then we're going to
calculate the probability
of generating that
particular sequence as given
plus-- meaning given
our foreground,
or motif model-- as the
product of the probability
of generating the first base in
sequence, S1, using the column
probability in the
minus 3 position.
So if the first base is AC,
for example, that would be 0.4.
And then the probability of
generating the second base
in the sequence using the
next column, and so forth.
If you made a vector for
each position that had a 1
for the base that
occurred at that position,
and a 0 for the other
bases, and then you
just did the dot product of that
with the matrix, you get this.
So, we multiply probabilities.
So that is assuming
independence between positions.
And so that's a key assumption--
weight matrices assume
that each position in the
motif contributes independently
to the overall
strength of that motif.
And that may or may not be
true-- they don't assume
that it's homogeneous,
that is you
have usually in a typical
case, different probabilities
in different columns,
so it's inhomogeneous,
but assumes independence.
And then you often want
to use a background model.
For example, if your
genome composition
is 25% of each of
the nucleotides,
you could just have a
background probability that
was equally likely
for each of the four,
and then calculate the
probability, S given minus,
of generating that
particular [INAUDIBLE]
under the background model, and
take the ratio of those two.
And the advantage of
that is that then you
can find sequences
that are-- that ratio,
it could be 100 times more
like a 5 prime splice site
than like background--
or 1,000 times.
Or you have some sort
of scaling on it.
Whereas, if you just
take the raw probability,
it's going to be something
that's on the order of 1/4
to a 1/9.
So some very, very small
number that's a little hard to
work with.
So when people
talk about motifs,
they often use language
like exact, or precise,
versus degenerate, strong
versus weak, good versus lousy,
depending on the
context, who's listening.
So an example of these would
be a restriction enzyme.
You often say
restriction enzymes have
very precise
sequence specificity,
they only cut-- echo
R1 only cuts a GAA TTC.
Whereas, a TATA binding protein
is somewhat more degenerate.
It'll bind to a range of things.
So I use degenerate there, you
could say it's a weaker motif.
You'll often-- if you want
to try to make this precise,
then the language of
entropy information
offers additional terminology,
like high information
content, low entropy, et cetera.
So let's take a look at this as
perhaps a more natural, or more
precise way of describing
what we mean, here.
So imagine you have a motif.
We're going to do a
motif of length one--
just keep the math
super simple, but you'll
see it easily generalizes.
So you have probabilities of the
four nucleotides that are Pk.
And you have background
probabilities, qk.
And we're going to assume
those are all uniform,
they're all a quarter.
So then the statistical,
or Shannon entropy
of a probability distribution--
or vector of probabilities,
if you will-- is defined here.
So H of q, where q is a
distribution or, in this case,
vector, is defined as minus
the summation of qk log qk,
in general.
And then if you wanted
to be in units of bits,
you'd use log base 2.
So how many people have
seen this equation before?
Like half, I'm going to go with.
OK, good.
So who can tell me
why, first of all--
is this a positive
quantity, negative quantity,
non-negative, or what?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Log qk is always
going to be negative.
And so therefore
you have to take
the negative of the sum
of all the negatives
to get a positive number.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so this, in general,
is a non-negative
quantity, because we
have this minus sign here.
We're taking logs of things
that are between 0 and 1.
So the logs are negative, right?
OK.
And then what would be
the entropy if I say that
the distribution q is
this-- 0100, meaning,
it's a motif that's 100% C?
What is the entropy of that?
What was your name?
AUDIENCE: William.
PROFESSOR: William.
AUDIENCE: So the
entropy would be 0,
because the vector is determined
in respect of the known
certainty.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And we do the math--
you'll get, for the C term,
you'll have a sum.
You'll have three
terms that are 0 log
0-- it might crash your
calculator, I guess.
And then you'll have one
term that is 1 log 1.
And so 1 log 1, that's easy.
That's 0, right?
This, you could
say, is undefined.
But using L'Hospital's rule--
by continuity, x log x,
you take the limit,
as x gets small, is 0.
So this is defined to be
0 in information theory.
And this is always, always 0.
So that comes out to be 0.
So it's deterministic.
So entropy is a
measure of uncertainty,
and so that makes sense-- if
you know what the base is,
there's no uncertainty,
entropy is 0.
So what about this vector-- 1/4,
1/4, 25% of each of the bases,
what is H of q?
Anyone?
I'm going to make
you show me why,
so-- Anyone want
to attempt this?
Levi?
AUDIENCE: I think it's 2.
PROFESSOR: 2, OK.
Can you explain?
AUDIENCE: Because
the log of the 1/4's
is going to be negative 2.
And then you're
multiplying that by 1/4,
so you're getting 1/2 for each
and adding it up equals 2.
PROFESSOR: Right,
in sum, there are
going to be four terms that
are 1/4 times log of a 1/4.
This is minus 2, 1/4 times
minus 2 is minus 1/2,
4 times minus 1/2 is
minus 2, and then you
change the sign, because
there's this minus in front.
So that equals 2.
And what about this one?
Anyone see that one?
This is a coin flip, basically.
All right?
It's either A or G. [INAUDIBLE].
Anyone?
Levi, want to do this one again?
AUDIENCE: It's 1.
PROFESSOR: OK, and why?
AUDIENCE: Because you have two
terms of 0 log 0, which is 0.
And two terms of 1/2
times the log of 1/2,
which is just negative 1.
So you have 2 halves.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So two terms like that.
And then there's going
to be two terms that
are something that turns
out to be 0-- 0 log 0.
And then there's
a minus in front.
So that will be 1.
So a coin flip has one
bit of information.
So that's basically
what we mean.
If you have a fair coin and
you don't know the outcome,
we're going to
call that one bit.
And so a base that could be
any of the four equally likely
has twice as much uncertainty.
All right, and this is related
to the Boltzmann entropy
that you may be familiar with
from statistical mechanics,
which is the log of the number
of states, in that if you have
N states, and they're
all equally likely, then
it turns out that the
Shannon entropy turns out
to be log of the number states.
We saw that here-- four
states, equally likely,
comes out to be log of 4 or 2.
And that's true in general.
All right, so you
can think of this
as a generalization of Boltzmann
entropy, if you want to.
OK, so why did he
call it entropy?
So it turns out
that Shannon, who
was developing this
in the late '40s,
as developing a theory
of communication,
scratched his head a little bit.
And he talked to his friend,
John von Neumann-- none
other than him, involved
in inventing computers--
and he says, "My concern
was what to call it.
I thought of calling
it information.
But the word was overly used."
OK, so back in 1949, information
was already overused.
"And and so I decided
to call it uncertainty."
And then he discussed it
with John von Neumann,
and he had a better idea.
He said, "You should
call it entropy.
In the first place,
your certainly function
has already been used
in statistical mechanics
under that name," so
it already has a name.
"And the second place,
and more important,
nobody knows what entropy
really is, so in a debate,
you always have the advantage."
So keep that in mind.
After you've taken this class,
just start throwing it around
and you will win
a lot of debates.
So how is information
related to entropy?
So the way we're going
to define it here,
which is how it's
often defined, is
information is reduction
in uncertainty.
So, if I'm dealing
with an unknown DNA
sequence, the
lambda phage genome,
and it has 25% of each
base, if you tell me,
I'm going to send you two
bases, I have no idea.
They could be any pair of bases.
My uncertainty is
2 bits per base,
or 4 bits before you
tell me anything.
If you then tell me,
it's the TA motif,
which is always T followed
by A, then now my uncertainty
is 0, so the amount
of information
that you just gave me is 4 bits.
You reduced my uncertainty
from 4 bits to 0.
So we define the information
at a particular position
as the entropy
before-- before meaning
the background, the background
a sort of your null hypothesis--
minus the entropy after--
so after you've told me
that this is an
instance of that motif,
and it has a particular model.
So, in this case, you
can see the entropy
is going to be entropy before.
This is just H of q
right here, this term.
And then minus this
term, which is H of p.
So, if it's uniform, we said
H of q is 2 bits per position.
And so, so the information
content of the motif is just 2
minus the entropy
of that motif model.
In general, it turns out if
the positions in the motif
are independent, then
the information content
of the motif is 2w
minus H of motif,
where w is it
width of the motif.
So for example, the entropy
of the motif of-- we
said the entropy of
this is 2 bits, right?
Therefore, the information
content is what?
If this is our-- let's say this
is a P. This is our routine.
Are you starting to generate?
What is its information content?
AUDIENCE: 0?
PROFESSOR: 0.
Why is it 0?
Yeah, back row.
AUDIENCE: Because the
information content
of that is 0, and
then the information
content of the known
hypothesis, so to say, is 0.
Sorry, both of them are 2.
So 2 minus 2 is 0.
PROFESSOR: The entropy
of the background
is 2, and the entropy
if this is also 2.
So 2 minus 2 is 0.
And what about this?
Let's say this was
our motif, it's
a motif that's either A or G.
We said the entropy of this
is 1 bit, so what
is the information
content of this motif?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1, and why is it 1?
AUDIENCE: Background is
2, and entropy here is 1.
PROFESSOR: Background
is 2, entropy is 1.
OK?
And what about if I tell you
it's the echo R1 restriction
enzyme?
So it's GAA TTC,
a six-base motif
precise-- it has
to be those bases?
What is the information
content of that motif?
In the back?
AUDIENCE: It's 12.
PROFESSOR: 12-- 12 what?
AUDIENCE: 12 bits.
PROFESSOR: 12 bits,
and why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because the
background is 2 times 6.
So 6 bases, and 2 bits for each.
And you have all the
bases are determined
at the specific
[INAUDIBLE] enzyme site.
So the entropy of that is
0, since 12 minus 0 is 12.
PROFESSOR: Right, the
entropy of that motif is 0.
You imagine 4,096
possible six-mers.
One of them has probably 1.
All the others have 0.
You're going to
have that big sum.
It's going to come
out to be 0, OK?
Why is this useful
at all, or is it?
One of the reasons why
it's useful-- sorry,
that's on a later slide.
Well, just hang with
me, and it will be clear
why it's useful in a few slides.
But for now, we
have a description
of information content.
So the echo R1 site has
12 bits of information,
a completely random
position has 0,
and a short four-cutter
restriction enzyme
would have 2 times 4, 8
bits of information, right,
and an eight-cutter.
So you can see as the
restriction enzyme gets
longer, more
information content.
So let's talk about the
motif finding problem,
and then we'll return to the
usefulness of information
content.
So can everyone see
the motif that's
present in all these sequences?
If anyone can't,
please let me know.
You probably can't.
Now, what now?
These are the same sequences,
but I've aligned them.
Can anyone see a motif?
PROFESSOR: GGG GGG.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I heard some G's.
Right.
so there's this motif
that's over here.
It's pretty weak, and
pretty degenerate.
There's definitely
some exceptions,
but you can definitely see
that a lot of the sequences
have at least GGC,
possibly an A after that.
Right, so this is the
problem we're dealing with.
You have a bunch of promoters,
and the transcription factor
that binds may be fairly
degenerate, maybe because it
likes to bind cooperatively
with several of its buddies,
and so it doesn't
have to have a very
strong instance of
the motif present.
And so, it can be quite
difficult to find.
So that's why there's a real
bio-informatics challenge.
Motif finding is not done by
lining up sequences by hand,
and drawing boxes--
although that's
how the first motif was
found, the TATA box.
That's why it's called the
TATA box, because someone just
drew a box in a
sequence alignment.
But these days,
you need a computer
to find-- most motifs require
some sort of algorithm to find.
Like I said, it's essentially
a local multiple alignment
problem.
You want multiple alignment, but
it doesn't have to be global.
It just can be local, it can
be just over a sub-region.
There are basically at
least three different sort
of general approaches to the
problem of motif finding.
One approach is the so-called
enumerative, or dictionary,
approach.
And so in this
approach, you say,
well, we're looking
for a motif of length 6
because this is a leucine zipper
transcription factor that we're
modeling, and they usually
have binding sites around 6,
so we're going to guess 6.
And we're going to
enumerate all the six-mers,
there's 4,096 six-mers.
We're going to count
up their occurrences
in a set of promoters that, for
example, are turned on when you
over-express this
factor, and look
at those frequencies
divided by the frequencies
of those six-mers in
some background set--
either random sequences, or
promoters that didn't turn on.
Something like that.
You have two
classes, and you look
for statistical enrichment.
This approach, this is fine.
There's nothing wrong
with this approach.
People use it all the time.
One of the downsides,
though, is that you're
doing a lot of
statistical tests.
You're essentially
testing each six-mer--
you're doing 4,096
statistical tests.
So you have to adjust the
statistical significance
for the number of
tests that you do,
and that can reduce your power.
So that's one main drawback.
The other reason
is that maybe you
don't see-- maybe this protein
binds a rather degenerate
motif, and a precise
six-mer is just too precise.
None of them will
occur often enough.
You really have to have
a degenerate motif that's
C R Y G Y. That's really
the motif that it binds to,
and so you don't
see it unless you
use something more degenerate.
So you can generalize
this to use
regular expressions, et cetera.
And it's a reasonable approach.
Another approach that we'll
talk about in a moment
is probabilistic
optimization, where
you wander around the possible
space of possible motifs
until you find one
that looks strong.
And we'll talk about that.
And then they're deterministic
versions of this, like me.
We're going to focus
today on this second one.
Mostly because it's a little bit
more mysterious and interesting
as an algorithm.
And it's also [INAUDIBLE].
So, if the motif landscape
looked like this,
where imagine all
possible motifs,
you've somehow come up with a
2D lattice of the possible motif
sequences.
And then the strength of
that motif, or the degree
to which that motif description
corresponds to the 2 motif
is represented by
the height here.
Then, there's basically
one optimal motif,
and the closer you get to
that, the better fit it is.
Then our problem is going
to be relatively easy.
But it's also possible that
it looks something like this.
There's a lot of
sort of decoy motifs,
or weaker motifs that are
only slightly enriched
in the sequence space.
And so you can easily
get tripped up,
if you're wandering
around randomly.
We don't know a priori,
and it's probably not
as simple as the first example.
And so that's one
of the issues that
motivates these
stochastic algorithms.
So just to sort of
put this in context--
the Gibbs motif sampler that
we're going to be talking about
is a Monte Carlo
algorithm, so that just
means it's an algorithm
that basically does
some random sampling
somewhere in it,
so that the outcome
that you get isn't
necessarily deterministic.
Your run it at different
times, and you'll actually
get different
outputs, which can be
a little bit disconcerting
and annoying at times.
But it turns out to be
useful in some cases.
There's also a special case
of a Las Vegas algorithm,
where it knows when it
got be optimal answer.
But in general, not.
In general, you
don't know for sure.
So Gibbs motif
simpler is basically
a model where you have a
likelihood for generating
a set of sequences,
S. So imagine
you have 40 sequences that
are bacterial promoters, each
of 40 bases long, let's say.
That's your S. And so
what you want to do,
then, is consider a model that
there is a particular instance
of a motif you're
trying to discover,
at a particular position in
each one of those sequences.
Not necessarily
the same position,
just some position
in each sequence.
And we're going to describe
the composition of that motif
by a weight matrix.
OK, one of these matrices
that's of width, W, and then
has the four rows specifying
the frequencies of the four
nucleotides at that position.
The setup here is that you
want to calculate or think
about the probability of S comma
A, S is the actual sequences,
and A is basically a
vector that specifies
the location of the motif
instance in each of those 40
sequences.
You want to calculate that,
conditional on capital
theta-- which is
our weight matrix.
So that's going to
be, in this case,
I think I made a motif of length
8, and it's shown there in red.
There's going to be a
weight matrix of length 8.
And then there's going to
be some sort of background
frequency vector that
might be the background
composition in the genome
of E.coli DNA, for example.
And so then the probability
of generating those sequences
together with that
particular locations
is going to be
proportional to this.
Basically, use the little
theta background vector
for all the positions, except
the specific positions that
are inside the motif,
starting at position AK here.
And then you use the
particular column
of the weight matrix
for those 8 positions,
and then you go back to using
the background probabilities.
Question, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this
for finding motifs
based on other known motifs?
Or is this--
PROFESSOR: No, what
we're doing-- I'm sorry,
I should've prefaced that.
We're doing de
novo motif finding.
We're going to tell
the algorithm-- we're
going to give the algorithm some
sequences of a given length,
or it can even be
of variable lengths,
and we're going to
give it a guess of what
the length of the motif is.
So we're going to
say, we think it's 8.
That could come from
structural reasons.
Or often you really
have no idea,
so you just guess that
you know, a lot of times
it's kind of short, so we're
going to go with 6 or 8,
or you try different lengths.
Totally de novo motif finding.
OK, so how does algorithm work?
You have N sequences of
length, L. You guessed
that the motif has width, W.
You choose starting positions
at random-- OK, so this is
a vector, of the starting
position in each
sequence, we're going
to choose completely random
positions within the end
sequences.
They have to be at
least W before the end--
so we'll have a whole motif,
that's just an accounting thing
to make it simpler.
And then you choose one
of the sequence at random.
Say, the first sequence.
You make a weight matrix
model of width, W,
from the instances in
the other sequences.
So for example--
actually, I have
slides on this, so we'll
just do it with the slides,
you'll see what this
looks like in a moment.
And so you have instances
here in the sequence,
here in this one, here.
You take all those, line them
up, make a weight matrix out
of those, and then you score
the positions in sequence 1
for how well they match.
So, let me just do this.
These are your motif instances.
Again, totally random
at the beginning.
Then you build a weight
matrix from those
by lining them up, and
just counting frequencies.
Then you pick a sequence
at random-- yeah,
your weight matrix doesn't
include that sequence,
typically.
And then you take
your theta matrix
and you slide it
along the sequence.
You consider every
sub-sequence of length,
W-- the one that
goes from 1 to W,
to one that goes from
2 to W plus 1, et
cetera, all the way
along the sequence,
until you get to the end.
And you calculate the
probability of that sequence,
using that likelihood
that I gave you before.
So, it's basically the
probability generating sequence
where you use the background
vector for all the positions,
except for the particular
motif instance that you're
considering, and use the
motif model for that.
Does that make sense?
So, if you happen to have a good
looking occurrence of the motif
at this position,
here, in the sequence,
then you would get
a higher likelihood.
So for example, if the motif
was, let's say it's 3 long,
and it happened
to favor ACG, then
if you have a sequence
here that has,
let's say, it's got
TTT, that's going
to have a low probability
in this motif.
It's going to be 0.1 cubed.
And then if you have an
occurrence of, say, ACT,
that's going to have
a higher occurrence.
It's going to be 0.7
times 0.7 times 0.1.
So, quite a bit higher.
So you start, it'll be
low for this triplet
here-- so I'll put
a low value here.
TTA is also going to be low.
TAC, also low.
But ACT, that matches 2
out of 3 to the motif.
It's going to be a lot better.
And then CT is going to
be low again, et cetera.
So you just slide this along
and calculate probabilities.
And then what you do is you
sample from this distribution.
These probabilities don't
necessarily sum to 1.
But you re-normalize them
so that they do sum to 1,
you just add them up,
divide by the sum.
Now they sum to 1.
And now you sample those
sites in that sequence,
according to that
probability distribution.
Like I said, in this
case you might end up
sampling-- that's the
highest probability site,
so you might sample that.
But you also might sample
one of these other ones.
It's unlikely you
would sample this one,
because that's very low.
But you actually sometime
sample one that's not so great.
So you sample a starting
position in that sequence,
and you basically-- wherever
you would originally
assign in sequence 1, now you
move it to that new location.
We've just changed
the assignment
of where we think the motif
might be in that sequence.
And then you choose
another sequence
at random from your list.
Often you go through the
sequences sequentially,
and then you make a new
weight matrix model.
So how will that weight matrix
model differ from the last one?
Well it'll differ
because the instance
of the motif in sequence 1
is now at a new location,
in general.
I mean, you might have sampled
the exact same location you
started, but in
general it'll move.
And so now, you'll got a
slightly different weight
matrix.
Most of the data going
into it, N minus 1,
is going to be the same.
But one of them is
going to be different.
So it'll change a little bit.
You make a new weight
matrix, and then you
pick a new sequence.
You slide that weight
matrix along that sequence,
you get this distribution, you
sample from that distribution,
and you keep going.
Yeah, this was described
by Lorenz in 1993,
and I'll post that paper.
OK, so you sample a
portion with that,
and you update the location.
So now we sampled that
really high probably one,
so we moved the motif over
to that new orange location,
there.
I don't know if these
animations are helping at all.
And then you update
your weight matrix.
And then you iterate
until convergence.
So you typically have
a set of end sequences,
you go through them once.
You have a weight matrix, and
then you go through them again.
You go through a few times.
And maybe at a
certain point, you
end re-sampling the
same sites as you
did in the last iteration--
same exact sites.
You've converged.
Or, you keep track
of the theta matrices
that you get after going through
the whole set of sequences,
and from one
iteration to the next,
the theta matrix hasn't
really changed much.
You've converged.
So let's do an example of this.
Here I made up a motif, and
this is a representation
where the four bases have
these colors assigned to them.
And you can see that this
motif is quite strong.
It really strongly
prefers A at this position
here, and et cetera.
And I put it at the same
position in all the sequences,
just to make life simple.
And then a former student
in the lab, [INAUDIBLE],
he implemented the Gibb
Sample in Matlab, actually,
and made a little video
of what's going on.
So the upper part shows
the current weight matrix.
Notice it's pretty
random-looking
at the beginning.
And the right parts
show where the motif
is, or the position that
we're currently considering.
So this shows the
position that was last
sampled in the last round.
And this shows the
probability density
along each sequence of
what's the probability
that the motif occurs
at each particular place
in the sequence.
And that's what
happens over times.
So it's obviously very
fast, so I'll run it again
and maybe pause it partway.
We're starting from a
very random-looking motif.
This is what you get after not
too many iterations-- probably
like 100 or so.
And now you can see your motif--
your weight matrix is now quite
biased, and now favors A at
this position, and so forth.
And the locations of
your motif, most of them
are around this
position, around 6 or 7
in the sequence-- that's
where we put the motif in.
But not all, some of them.
And then you can see the
probabilities-- white is high,
black is low-- in
some sequences,
it's very, very
confident, the motif
is exactly at that position,
like this first sequence here.
And others, it's
got some uncertainty
about where the motif might be.
And then we let it
run a little bit more,
and it eventually
converges to being
very confident that the motif
has the sequence, A C G T A G C
A, and that it occurs at
that particular position
in the sequence.
So who can tell me why
this actually works?
We're choosing
positions at random,
updating a weight matrix,
why does that actually
help you find the real motif
that's in these sequences?
Any ideas?
Or who can make an argument
that it shouldn't work?
Yeah?
What was your name again?
AUDIENCE: Dan.
PROFESSOR: Dan, yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So, couldn't it,
sort of, in a certain situation
have different sub-motifs
that are also sort of rich,
and because you're
sampling randomly
you might be stuck inside
of those boundaries
where you're searching
your composition?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's good.
So Dan's point is
that you can get
stuck in sub-optimal
smaller or weaker motifs.
So that's certainly true.
So you're saying, maybe
this example is artificial?
Because I had started with
totally random sequences,
and I put a pretty strong
motif in a particular place,
so there were no-- it's
more like that mountain,
that structure where there's
just one motif to find.
So it's perhaps an easy case.
But still, what I want to know
is how does this algorithm,
how did it actually
find that motif?
He implemented exactly that
algorithm that I described.
Why does it tend to go
towards [INAUDIBLE]?
After a long time,
remember it's a long time,
it's hundreds of iterations.
AUDIENCE: So you're covering
a lot in the sequence,
just the random searching of
the sequence, when you're--
PROFESSOR: There
are many iterations.
You're considering
many possible locations
within the sequences,
that's true.
But why does it eventually-- why
does it converge to something?
AUDIENCE: I guess,
because you're
seeing your motif more
plainly than you're
seeing other random motifs.
So it will hit it more
frequently-- randomly.
And therefore,
converge [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's true.
Can someone give a more
intuition behind this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I just
have a question.
Is each iteration
an independent test?
For example, if you iterate
over the same sequence base
100 times, and you're updating
your weight matrix each time,
does that mean it is the
updating the weight matrix also
taking into account
that the previous--
that this is the
same sample space?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
the weight matrix,
after you go through one
iteration of all the sequences,
you have a weight matrix.
You carry that over, you
don't start from scratch.
You bring that weight
matrix back up,
and use that to score, let's
say, that first sequence.
Yeah, the weight matrix
just keeps moving around.
Moves a little bit every
time you sample a sequence.
AUDIENCE: So you constantly
get a strong [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, does it?
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess--
PROFESSOR: Would it
constantly get stronger?
What's to make it get
stronger or weaker?
I mean, this is sort
of-- you're on the track.
AUDIENCE: If it is
random, then there's
some probability that you're
going to find this motif again,
at which point it
will get stronger.
But, if it's-- given
enough iterations,
it gets stronger as long as you
hit different spots at random.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm-- I think
there was a comment.
Jacob, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, you can think
about it as a random walk
through the landscape.
Eventually, it has
a high probability
of taking that motif, and
updating the [INAUDIBLE]
direction, just from the
probability of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: And given
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, let's say I
had 100 sequences of length,
I don't know, 30.
And the width of the motif is 6.
So here's our sequences.
We choose random positions
for the start position,
and let's say it was
this example where
the real motif, I put it right
here, and all the sequences.
That's where it starts.
Does this help?
So it's 30 and 6, so there's
25 possible start positions.
I did that to make
it a little easier.
So what would happen in
that first iteration?
What w can you say
about what the weight
matrix would look like?
It's going to be a width, W, you
know, columns 1, 2, 3, up to 6.
We're going to give it
100 positions at random.
The motif is here--
let's say it's
a very strong motif,
that's a 12-bit motif.
So it's 100%-- it's echo R1.
It's that.
What would that weight
matrix look like,
in this first iteration,
when you first
just sample the sites at random?
What kind of probabilities
would it have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Equal?
OK-- perfectly equal?
AUDIENCE: Roughly.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Any box?
Are we likely to hit
the actual motif, ever,
in that first encryption?
AUDIENCE: No, because you
have a uniform probability,
of sampling.
Well, uniform at each
one of the 25 positions?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Right now, you're
not sampling proportional
to the likelihood.
PROFESSOR: So the chance of
hitting the motif in any given
sequence is what?
AUDIENCE: 1/25.
PROFESSOR: 1/25.
We have 100 sequences.
AUDIENCE: So that's
four out of--
PROFESSOR: So on average,
I'll hit the motif four times,
right.
The other 96 positions will
be essentially random, right?
So you initially said this was
going to be uniform, right?
On average, 25% of each
base, plus or minus
a little bit of sampling
error-- could be 23, 24, 26.
But now, you pointed out
that it's going to be four.
You're going to hit the
motif four times, on average.
So, can you say anything more?
AUDIENCE: Could you maybe
have a slightly bias towards G
on the first position?
Slightly biased towards A
on the second and third?
Slightly biased towards T
on the fourth and fifth.
And slightly biased
towards C in the sixth?
So it would be slightly biased--
PROFESSOR: Right, so
remind me of your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Eric.
PROFESSOR: Eric,
OK, so Eric says
that because four
of the sequences
will have a G at
the first position,
because those are the ones
where you sampled the motif,
and the other 96 will have
each of the four bases equally
likely, on average you have
like 24%-- plus 4 for G, right?
Something like
28%-- this will be
28%, plus or minus a little bit.
And these other ones will be
whatever that works out to be,
23 or something like
that-- 23-ish, on average.
Again, it may not
come out exactly
like-- G may not be number
one, but it's more often
going to be number one
than any other base.
And on average, it'll be more
like 28% rather than 25%.
And similarly for
position two, A
will be 28%, and
three, and et cetera.
And then the sixth
will be-- C will
have a little bit of a bias.
OK, so even in that
first round, when
you're sampling
that first sequence,
the matrix is going
to be slightly biased
toward the motif-- depending
how the sampling went.
You might not have hit any
instances of motif, right?
But often, it'll
be a little bit--
Is that enough of
a bias to give you
a good chance of selecting the
motif in that first sequence?
AUDIENCE: You mean in
the first iteration?
PROFESSOR: Let's say the first
random sequence size sample.
No.
You're shaking your head.
Not enough of a
bias because-- it's
0.28 over 0.25 to the
sixth power, right?
So it's like--
AUDIENCE: The likelihood
is still close 1.
Like, that's [INAUDIBLE] ratio.
PROFESSOR: So it's something
like 1.1 to the sixth,
or something like that.
So it might be close to 2,
might be twice as likely.
But still, there's 25 positions.
Does that make sense?
So it's quite likely
that you won't
sample the motif in that first--
you'll sample something else.
Which will take it away
in some random direction.
So who can tell me how this
actually ends up working?
Why does it actually
converge eventually,
if you get it long enough?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the
information content,
what will happen to that?
So the information content,
if it was completely random--
we said that would be uniform.
That would be zero
information content, right?
This matrix, which has around
28% at six different positions,
will have an information content
that's low, but non-zero.
It might end up being
like 1 bit, or something.
And if you then sample motifs
that are not the motif,
they will tend to reduce
the information content,
tend to bring it
back toward random.
If you sample locations
that have the motif,
what will that do to
the information content?
Boost it.
So what would you expect if we
were to plot the information
content over time, what
would that look like?
AUDIENCE: It should
trend upwards,
but it could fluctuate.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Over the
number of iterations?
PROFESSOR: I think
I blocked it here.
Let me see if I
can-- Let's try this.
I think I plotted it.
OK, never mind.
I wanted to keep
it very mysterious,
so you guys have
to figure it out.
The answer is that it will--
basically what happens is you
start with a weight
matrix like this.
A lot of times, because the bias
for the motif is quite weak,
a lot of times
you'll sample-- even
for a sequence,
what matters is--
like, if you had a sequence
where the location, initially,
was not the motif, and then you
sample another location that's
not the motif, that's not
really going to change anything.
It'll change things
a little bit,
but not in any
particular direction.
What really matters is
when you get to a sequence
where you already had the motif,
if you now sample one that's
not the motif, your information
content will get weaker.
It will become more uniform.
But if you have a sequence
where it wasn't the motif,
but now you happen to sample the
motif, then it'll get stronger.
And when it gets
stronger, it will then
be more likely to pick the
motif in the next sequence,
and so on.
So basically what happens
to the information content
is that over many
iterations-- it starts near 0.
And can occasionally
go up a little bit.
And then once it exceeds the
threshold, it goes like that.
So what happens is it
stumbles onto a few instances
of the motif that bias
the weight matrix.
And if they don't
bias it enough,
it'll just fall off that.
It's like trying to
climb the mountain--
but it's walking in
a random direction.
So sometimes it will turn
around and go back down.
But then when it gets high
enough, it'll be obvious.
Once you have a, say, 20
times greater likelihood
of picking that motif than
any other sequence, most
of the time you will pick it.
And very soon,
it'll be stronger.
And the next round,
when it's stronger,
you'll have a greater
bias for picking
the motif, and so forth.
Question?
AUDIENCE: For this
specific example,
M is much greater
than L minus W.
How true is that for
practical examples?
PROFESSOR: That's a
very good question.
There is sometimes-- depends on
how commonly your motif occurs
in the genome, and how
good your data is, really,
and what the source
of your data is.
So sometimes it can
be very limited,
sometimes-- If you do
ChIP-Seq you might have 10,000
peaks that you're
analyzing, or something.
So you could have a huge number.
But on the other hand, if
you did some functional
assay that's quite laborious for
a motif that drives luciferase,
or something, and you
can only test a few,
you might only have 10.
So it varies all over the map.
So that's a good question.
We'll come back to
that in a little bit.
Simona?
AUDIENCE: If you
have a short motif,
does it make sense,
then, to reduce
the number of
sequences you have?
Because maybe it won't converge?
PROFESSOR: Reduce the
number of sequences?
What do you people
think about that?
Is that a good
idea or a bad idea?
It's true that it
might converge faster
with a smaller
number of sequences,
but you also might
not find it all.
So generally you're
losing information,
so you want to
have more sequences
up to a certain point.
Let's just do a couple more
examples, and I'll come back.
Those are both good questions.
OK, so here's this weak motif.
So this is the one where
you guys couldn't see it
when I just put
the sequences up.
You can only see it
when it's aligned--
it's this thing with GGC, here.
And here is, again,
the Gibbs Sampler.
And what happened?
Who can summarize
what happened here?
Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: It didn't converge.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it
didn't quite converge.
The motif is usually
on the right side,
and it found something
that's like the motif.
But it's not quite right--
it's got that A, it's G A G C,
it should be G G C. And so
it sampled some other things,
and it got off
track a little bit,
because probably
by chance, there
were some things that looked
a little bit like the motif,
and it was finding
some instances of that,
and some instances
of the real motif.
And yeah, it didn't
quite converge.
And you can see this
probability vectors here,
they have multiple white
dots in many of the rows.
So it doesn't know,
it's uncertain.
So it keeps bouncing around.
So it didn't really
converge, it was too weak,
it was too challenging
for the algorithm.
This is just a summary of the
Gibb Sampler, how it works.
It's not guaranteed to converge
to the same motif every time.
So what you generally will want
to do is run it several times,
and nine out of 10 times,
you get the same motif.
You should trust that.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Over here, are we
optimizing for convergence
of the value of the
information content?
PROFESSOR: No, the
information content
is just describing-- it's
just a handy single number
description of how biased
the weight matrix is.
So it's not actually
directly being optimized.
But it turns out that
this way of sampling
tends to increase
information content.
It's sort of a self-reinforcing
kind of a thing.
But it's not
directly doing that.
However MEME, more or
less, directly does that.
The problem with that is
that, where do you start?
Imagine an algorithm
like this, but where
you deterministically--
instead of sampling
from the positions in the
sequence, where it might have
a motif in proportion
to probabilities,
you just chose the one that
had the highest probability.
That's more or less
what MEME does.
And so what are
the pros and cons
of that approach,
versus this one?
Any ideas?
OK, one of the disadvantages
is that the initial choice
of-- how you're initially
seeding your matrix,
matters a lot.
That slight bias-- it might
be that you had a slight bias,
and it didn't come out
being G was number one.
It was actually-- T was
number one, just because
of the quirks of the sampling.
So what would this
be, 31 or something?
Anyway, it's higher
than these other guys.
And so then you're always
picking the highest.
It'll become a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
So that's the problem with MEME.
So the way that MEME
gets around that,
is it uses multiple
different seeding,
multiple different
starting points,
and goes to the end
with all of them.
And then it evaluates, how good
a model did we get at the end?
And whichever was the
best one, it takes that.
So it actually takes
longer, but you only
need to run it once
because it's deterministic.
You use a deterministic
set of starting points,
you run a deterministic
algorithm,
and then you evaluate.
The Gibbs, it can
go off on a tangent,
but because it's
sampling so randomly,
it often will fall off,
then, and come back
to something that's
more uniform.
And when it's a
uniform matrix, it's
really sampling
completely randomly,
exploring the space
in an unbiased way.
Tim?
AUDIENCE: For genomes that have
inherent biases that you know
going in, do you precalculate--
do you just recalculate
the weight matrix before, to
[? affect  those  classes? ?]
For example, if you
had 80% AT content,
then you're not looking
for-- you know, immediately,
that you're going to hit an A
or a T off the first iteration.
So how do you deal with that?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
So these are some features
that affect motif finding.
I think that we've now hit at
least a few of these-- number
of sequences, length of
sequences, information content,
and motif, and basically
whether the background is biased
or not.
So, in general, higher
information content motifs,
or lower information
content, are easier to find--
who thinks higher?
Who thinks lower?
Someone, can you explain?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I just guessed.
PROFESSOR: Just a guess?
OK, in back, can you explain?
Lower?
AUDIENCE: Low
information content
is basically very uniform.
PROFESSOR: Low information
means nearly uniform-- right,
those are very hard to find.
That's like that GGC one.
The high information
content motif,
those are the very strong
ones, like that first one.
Those are much easier to find.
Because when you
stumble on to them,
it biases the matrix more, and
you rapidly converge to that.
OK, high information
is easy to find.
So if I have one
motif per sequence,
what about the length
of the sequence?
Is longer or shorter better?
Is long better?
Who thinks shorter is better?
Shorter-- can you
explain why short?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it be
the smaller the search space,
the fewer the problems?
PROFESSOR: Exactly, the
shorter the search space,
and your motif, there's
less place for it to hide.
You're more likely to sample it.
Shorter is better.
If you think about-- if you
have a motif like TATA, which
is typically 30
bases from the TSS,
if you happen to know that, and
you give it plus 1 to minus 50,
you're giving it a
small region, you
can easily find the TATA box.
If you give it plus 1 to
minus 2,000 or something,
you may not find it.
It's diluted, essentially.
Number of sequences--
the more the better.
This is a little more
subtle, as Simona was saying.
It affects convergence
time, and so forth.
But in general, the
more the better.
And if you guessed the
wrong length of your matrix,
that makes it worse
than if you guess
the right length in
either direction.
For example, it's six-base
motif, you guess three.
The information content,
even if it's a 12-bit motif,
there's only six bits that
you could hope to find,
because you can only find
three of those positions.
So clearly, effectively
it's a smaller information
content, and much
harder to find.
And vice versa.
Another thing that
occurs in practice
is what's called shifted motifs.
Your motif is G A A T T C.
Imagine in your first iteration
you happen to hit several of
these sequences, starting here.
You hit the motif,
but off by two
at several different places.
That'll bias first
position to be
A, and the second position
to be T, and so forth.
And then you tend to find other
shifted versions of that motif.
You may well converge to this--
A T C C N N, or something
like that-- which
is not quite right.
It's close, you're very
close, but not quite right.
And it's not as information
rich as the real motif.
Because it's got those two N's
at the end, instead of G A.
So one thing that's
done in practice
is a lot of times, every so
often, the algorithm will say,
what would happen if we
shifted all of our positions
over to the left by one or two?
Or to the right by one or two?
Would the information
content go up?
If so, let's do that.
So basically, shifted
versions of the motif become
local, near-optimal solutions.
So you have to avoid them.
And biased background
composition
is very difficult to deal with.
So I will just give
you one or two more
examples of that in a
moment, and continue.
So in practice, I would say
the Gibbs Sampler is sometimes
used, or AlignACE, which is
a version of Gibbs Sampler.
But probably more
often, people use
an algorithm called MEME, which
is this EM algorithm, which,
like I said, is
deterministic, so you always
get the same answer,
which makes you feel good.
May or may not always be right,
but you can try it out here
at this website.
And actually, the
Fraenkel Lab has
a very nice website
called WebMotifs
that runs several different
motif finders including,
like I said, a MEME
and AlignACE, which
is similar to Gibbs,
as well as some others.
And it integrates the output,
so that's often a handy thing
to use.
You can read about them there.
And then I just wanted
to say a couple words--
this is related to Tim's comment
about the biased background.
How do you actually
deal with that?
And this related to this notion
of a mean bit score of a motif.
So if I were to give you a
motif model, P, and a background
model, q, then the natural
scoring system, if you wanted
additives scores, instead
of multiplicative,
you would just take the log.
So log P over q, I would argue,
is natural additive scores.
And that's often what you'll
see in a weight matrix-- you'll
see log probabilities, or logs
of ratios of probabilities.
And so then you
just add them up,
and it makes life a bit simpler.
And so then, if you were to
calculate what's the mean bit
score-- if I had a bunch
of instances of a motif,
it will be given by this formula
that's here in the upper right.
So that's your score.
And this is the mean,
where you're sampling over
the probability in using the
motif model, probabilities.
So it turns out, then, that
if qk, your background,
is uniform, motif of width
w-- so its probability
of any w-mer, is
1/4 to the w, then
it's true that the
mean bit-score is
2w minus the entropy
of the motif, which
is the same as the information
content of the motif,
using our previous definition.
So that's just a
handy relationship.
And you can do a little algebra
to show that, if you want.
So basically summation Pk
log Pk over qk-- this log,
you turn that into
a difference--
so that summation Pk
log Pk minus Pk log qk.
And then you can do some
rearrangement, and sum them up,
and you'll get this formula.
I'll leave that as an exercise,
and any questions on it,
we can do it next time.
So what I wanted to get to
is sort of this big question
that I posed earlier--
what's the use of knowing
the information
content of a motif?
And the answer is that one use
is that it's true, in general,
that the motif with
n bits of information
will occur about once every 2 to
the n bases of random sequence.
So we said a six-cutter
restriction enzyme, echo R1,
has an information
content of 12 bits.
So by this rule, it should
occur about once every
to 2 to the 12th
bases of sequence.
And if you know your powers
of 2, which you should all
commit to memory,
that's about 4,000.
2 to the 12th is 4 to
the sixth, is 4,096.
So it'll occur about once
every 4 [? kb, ?] which
if you've ever cut E. coli
DNA, you know is about right--
your fragments come out
to be about 4 [? kb. ?]
So this turns out to be
strictly true for any motif
that you can represent
by a regular expression,
like a precise
motif, or something
where you have a degenerate R
or Y or N in it, still true.
And if you have a more
general motif that's
described by weight matrix, then
you have to define a threshold,
and it's roughly
true, but not exactly.
All right, so what do you
do when the background
composition is biased,
like Tim was saying?
What if it's 80%, A plus T?
So then, it turns out that this
mean bit-score is a good way
to go.
So like I said,
the mean bit-score
equals the information
content in this special case,
where the background is uniform.
But if the background
is not uniform,
then you can still calculate
this mean bit-score,
and it'll still be meaningful.
But now it's called
something else--
it's called relative entropy.
Actually it has several
names, relative entropy,
Kullback-Leibler
distance is another,
and information
for discrimination,
depending whether you're
reading the Double
E literature, or
statistics, or whatever.
And so it turns out
that if you have
a very biased composition--
so here's one that's 75% A T,
probability of A and T
are 3/8, C and G are 1/8.
If your motif is just
C 100% of the time,
your information content
by the original formula
that I gave you,
would be 2 bits.
However, the relative
entropy will be 3 bits,
if you just plug in these
numbers into this formula,
it will turn out to be 3 bits.
My question is, which
one better describes
the frequency of C in
the background sequence?
Frequency of this
motif-- the motif
is just a C. You can see that
the relative entropy says
that actually, that's
stronger than it appears.
Because it's a C, and
that's a rare nucleotide,
it's actually stronger
than it appears.
And so 2 to the 3rd
is a better estimate
of its frequency than 2 squared.
So relative entropy.
So what you can do
when you run a motif
finder in a sequence
of biased composition,
you can say, what's
the relative entropy
of this motif at the end?
And look at the ones
that are strong.
We'll come back to this
a little more next time.
Next time, we'll talk
about hidden Markov models,
and please take a
look at the readings.
And please, those who
are doing projects,
look for more
detailed instructions
to be posted tonight.
Thanks.